who can you trust in a world of
shapeshifters super spy Nick Fury is
about to find out secret invasion is
almost here so here's a dossier for fans
before the big Disney plus premiere
the folks over at Marvel Studios are
well known for planning their release
dates well in advance however things
have gotten a bit unpredictable in the
MCU with the Marvels being pushed back
several months and talks of shuffling
multiple series further down the release
schedule it also looks like secret
invasions suffered a bit in this
upheaval originally it was reported we'd
see the series hit Disney Plus in the
spring of 2023 now we finally know when
Nick Fury will reappear the secret
Invasion will commence on June 21st 2023
as one of the first projects of The
mcu's Phase 5 that means we may feel the
series Ripple effects in feature films
like the Marvels Captain America a new
world order and armor Wars similar to
other Disney plus series like Loki Moon
Knight and the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier we can expect six episodes of
thrilling spy action when secret
Invasion premieres
we last Saw Nick Fury in 2019's
Spider-Man far from home while we were
led to believe that the ex-shield agent
had teamed up with Peter Parker to
defeat Mysterio it turned out that Fury
had actually been the squirrel Talos in
Disguise so where was the one-eyed spy
himself in a post-credits scene we saw
the real Fury hanging out in a scroll
spaceship but what was he doing up there
Samuel L Jackson told Vanity Fair in
March 2023 even Nick Fury can be shaken
you know he's up there trying to process
what the happened you know and what
his place in the world is the death of
Iron Man the death of Black Widow with
that stuff going on he just kind of
checked out during his absence Maria
Hill has been trying her best to fill
Fury's shoes while growing increasingly
upset that her old boss hasn't been
returning her calls but I have called
for your help plenty of other times and
you've been pretty content to let those
calls go straight to voicemail
however Fury is back on earth now after
receiving some truly disturbing news it
looks like a rogue faction of Scrolls
led by the radical graphic has grown
tired of the status quo they're sick of
talos's leadership and they're pretty
disappointed in Nick Fury Jackson
continued in his interview he told the
Scrolls they were trying to find them a
place to live he promised them they were
going to find them a planet or somewhere
they could be and that's not going so
well since they don't have a Homeworld
of their own graphic and his cohorts
have decided to take over ours and
they've been doing that by inserting
themselves into Political positions of
power now a returning Fury must team up
with a Cadre of returning and new Marvel
characters to stop these shape-shifters
from extending their reach and using
their influence for nefarious purposes
of course that's easier said than done
when your enemies can make themselves
look exactly like your allies
MCU projects never skimp when it comes
to Big actors and big characters aimed
the same is true for secret Invasion
needless to say Samuel L Jackson will be
reprising his role as Nick Fury
alongside his longtime sidekick Kobe
smolders Maria Hill only this version of
Hill won't be too happy with Fury
smolders revealed in a Vanity Fair
interview I think Maria Hill has really
run out of patience she's always had
this really close relationship with Nick
Fury but he's been gone for so long and
she's just been running around putting
out fires we can also expect to see
Martin Freeman return as ex-cia agent
Everett K Ross who was arrested in
wakanda forever but freed by Midnight
Angel Okoye Ben Mendelson returns as
Fury's scroll Ally Talos and Don Cheadle
will appear as Colonel James Roadie
Rhodes the war machine this version of
roadie will be a little more politically
minded and serves as a close Ally to the
president of the United States
interestingly the events of secret
Invasion will reportedly tie into
rhodey's upcoming film armor Wars you
should also expect to see plenty of
newcomers the Mother of Dragons herself
Emilia Clarke shows up as a rogue scroll
named Gaia talus's daughter Oscar winner
Olivia Coleman is reportedly playing
special agent Sonya fallsworth and
Kingsley benedir of one night in Miami
Fame plays the rebel scroll gravic
Landing a show running gig in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is a pretty big deal
and it's introduced a group of
filmmakers to wider audiences everywhere
Kyle Bradstreet joins that list serving
as the head writer and executive
producer for secret Invasion up until
recently Bradstreet was most famous for
writing and producing the show that put
Rami Malek on the map the USA Network's
Mr Robot of course well he'll guide the
new Marvel series he won't be the only
creative behind the scenes joining the
pantheon of the mcu's Disney plus
directors like Matt shackman Adele lrb
Bilal fala and Kate Heron will be Thomas
bazooka and Ali Saleem
since secret invasion was first
announced fans were understandably
excited about the potentials surrounding
this Marvel story originally published
between June 2008 and January 2009
Marvel Comics secret invasion was the
first massive crossover event since
Civil War that United the entire Marvel
Universe the events affected everyone
from the different factions of X-Men and
Avengers to the Fantastic Four the Young
Avengers and the Inhumans it changed the
landscape of the Marvel Universe for
years to come secret Invasion follows
the discovery that the shape-shifting
Scrolls have replaced many of Earth's
heroes and villains in an attempt to
the world before an
interplanetary invasion this brought
many of the Avengers back together after
the events of Civil War and United
heroes and villains alike against a
common enemy at one point Tony Stark was
almost convinced that he was a scroll
before being saved by his friends and
allies leading the Scrolls is Princess
for Anki who has posed as the superhero
Spider Woman and infiltrated the new
Avengers in the Years leading up to her
reveal while the Marvel Cinematic
Universe version of secret Invasion
looks to be fairly different it's still
based primarily on the original story
written by Brian Michael Bendis and with
art by Lanell Francis u in preparation
for the series Marvel is currently
publishing a sequel to the original
secret Invasion series
secret invasion is set to be a bit
different from Marvel's original story
of the same name rather than focusing in
on the two factions of the Avengers one
led by Iron Man and the other by Luke
Cage as in the comics the live action
series will focus on the Journey of
Samuel L Jackson's Nick Fury as he
uncovers the secret War around him he
enlists a group of selected and trusted
allies including Ben Mendelson's Talos
to help him defeat the Alien Invaders
while there may be some character
crossovers from the comics to the screen
Marvel Studios adaptation seems to be
playing everything a bit more grounded
than some of their most recent projects
this war is one I have
to sign from the serious lack of
superheroes the plans of the Scrolls in
the upcoming secret Invasion series seem
to be more covert than their comic book
counterparts while a full-scale alien
invasion served as the climax of the
original Marvel comics series the Disney
plus production looks to be taking
things in a different direction it's
entirely possible that there won't be a
public invasion at all but rather a
continued Shadow War fought by a select
few think something more like the
X-Files than Independence Day which
makes Jackson's Fury a bit more akin to
Agent Fox Mulder
as the first Disney plus series of
Marvel's official Phase 5 secret
invasion is the beginning of something
bigger though phase 4 was admittedly a
bit confusing especially regarding when
everything takes place on the timeline
we're hopeful that secret Invasion will
be a bit more straightforward Phase 5
occurs after the events of black panther
wakanda forever and She-Hulk attorney at
law so we can rest assured that
everything released before those Series
has already happened by the time we
catch up with Nick Fury both Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania and Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 were released before a
secret Invasion and they effectively
started the Marvel Cinematic universe's
fifth phase as to where exactly on the
timeline secret Invasion rests remains
to be seen just because the limited
series is being released before or after
certain projects does not necessarily
correlate to its place on the greater
timeline for example Black Widow was the
first film of phase four but it
technically took place in between the
events of Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end game at the tail end of
phase three well secret invasion in June
2023 helps us navigate when to watch it
it might not fit in nicely with the
greater story Marvel Studios is telling
though they'll no doubt issue an
official timeline watching order
sometime in the future most likely as a
playlist on Disney Plus
from the first glimpses of secret
Invasion it's clear that the whole thing
feels a bit more like an
espionage-fueled spy Thriller than a
comic book inspired superhero story
whether you love or hate that change
it's clear that Marvel Studios is
destroying something different this time
around this leans more into the
political landscape they first explored
with the second Captain America film
Ed
series producer Jonathan Schwartz who
has been with Marvel Studios since phase
one told Vanity Fair that the series
took its inspiration from different spy
Thrillers like Homeland and the
Americans he also cites the works of
John le carre a cold war author as
Paramount to the themes of loyalty and
identity he said what you find is there
are people that you trust or you think
you can trust or you can only trust to a
certain point this statement further
enforces the Cold War era paranoia that
will no doubt Mark the series Ben
Mendelson further explained to Vanity
Fair that the series takes its time to
analyze the tensions between the
different factions of Scrolls he said
the Cold War stuff is the big one that
jumps out but there is plenty of strife
between groups of people that this
addresses as tensions escalate one thing
is abundantly clear secret invasion is
not a Marvel story to sleep on
especially for fans of spy movies and
political Intrigue at an interplanetary
level
at the end of Avengers Infinity War Nick
Fury and Maria Hill are erased after
thanos's snap upon his return in
Avengers end game Fury attends Tony
Stark's funeral where he presumably
Mourns the loss of Black Widow his top
agent as well Fury waits to reappear in
Spider-Man far from home where he
recruits Spider-Man to help him and
Mysterio with the collapse of the
Multiverse except it's actually Talos in
Disguise Fury is off-world in the far
from home after credit scene we see the
actual Fury alive and well in outer
space policing the Galaxy and protecting
Earth from foreign threats we still
don't know how long he was gone how long
Talos was disguised as him or what he
was doing on the scroll ship more than
likely secret Invasion will reveal the
truth about Fury's sabbatical and
further explore his extraterrestrial
Adventures hopefully the more answers we
get regarding his time abroad the closer
he gets to discovering the scroll's
heinous plot to invade our world maybe
he was busy gathering an
extraterrestrial Avengers Initiative
in the trailer for the upcoming the
Marvels Fury is seen in command on the
saber space station above Earth what he
is doing there is unknown but he's in
contact with agent Monica Rambo his old
Ally Carol Danvers and newcomer Kamala
Khan to help figure out why their powers
are Tangled and disrupted since the
Marvels comes out months after secret
Invasion it's safe to assume that the
Disney plus series will take place
before the events of the feature film
but it's unclear if Marvel is playing
games with us again could the fury scene
and the Marvel's trailer be Talos in
Disguise again if this is Fury then we
know that he survives the events of
secret Invasion and that his last line
in the trailer is nothing more than a
dramatic read on his most recent solo
Adventure
one last fight
but if this isn't actually Fury and
Talos is continuing his friend's Legacy
then we must wonder what happened to the
original director of Shield however
secret Invasion goes we know that we'll
see Jackson in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe again which is something of a
comfort and fury will continue to have
some sort of presence moving forward
while Marvel has duped us before we have
no reason to think Fury won't appear in
the Marvels
in the early 1960s and one of the
earliest issues of the original
Fantastic Four comic book series a
scroll named clert first appeared to
battle Marvel's Flagship family of
superheroes unlike the previous
shape-shifting Scrolls the super scroll
was genetically engineered by his race
to copy the powers of the super-powered
family the super scroll could stretch
turn invisible emit fire from his body
and was as strong as the thing clerch
quickly became one of The Four's
greatest opponents but the same
techniques used on the super scroll
weren't forgotten during the secret
Invasion Arc it's revealed that the
scroll Empire has successfully recreated
their super scroll program on other
soldiers too pulling in power sets from
Avengers X-Men Inhumans and more so far
in the MCU we have only seen the Scrolls
appear in 2019's Captain Marvel and
briefly in Spider-Man far from home in
those movies the only abilities they
exhibit are their classic shape-shifting
tricks nevertheless in the trailer for
secret Invasion there is a single frame
of a scroll Warrior who manages to turn
his entire arm into to a batch of
tentacled objects it makes us wonder if
the live-action Scrolls have also found
ways to mimic the superpowers of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes if they have that might
make this secret Invasion just as deadly
and dangerous as in the original Marvel
comic books without a batch of
super-powered Heroes to face them the
stakes are only going up like many
Marvel Studios Productions secret
invasion was filmed largely in London
apparently at the same time as other big
Marvel Productions Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and the Marvels while
Jackson didn't appear in the latest
Ant-Man flick it seems like he was
shooting his Disney plus debut and the
upcoming Captain Marvel follow-up
simultaneously making us wonder how much
the two stories cross over shooting
locations for secret Invasion include
peace Hall in Halifax and West Yorkshire
as with most Marvel Productions Pinewood
Studios in England provided the sound
stages for the upcoming streaming series
based on the trailers alone it seems as
if secret invasion is set to take place
all across the globe while Europe is
likely the primary setting it would be
surprising if Nick Fury didn't hop back
over to America at some point during the
series run likewise with the title like
secret Invasion and the inclusion of
extraterrestrial scroll forces we may
Venture into outer space at some point
in the show after Spider-Man far from
home and the latest trailer for the
Marvels we're hoping to see Fury and his
new extraterrestrial element
most of Marvel Studios streaming series
have been one and done Productions from
Falcon and the Winter Soldier and one
division to Hawkeye and Ms Marvel many
of these shows were launching points for
greater MCU stories rather than
long-running shows Falcon serves as a
transition piece from Avengers end game
to the upcoming Captain America new
world order one division served as a
sort of prequel to the events of Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness and
Ms Marvel was about introducing the
titular heroine into the MCU before her
appearance in the Marvels with so many
different Marvel stories out there it's
easy to wonder if secret Invasion will
fall into the same limited series Banner
according to collider Kevin feige wanted
to do Secret Invasion as a six episode
limited event series because it allowed
Marvel to do quote something different
than we've done before unlike Loki and
what if which are getting subsequent
Seasons secret invasion is a one-off
that will reportedly change the
landscape of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe while we don't know exactly how
it will change we do know that the
limited series is a complete
self-contained story
single films or television shows can
profoundly affect the larger Marvel
world the Winter Soldier exemplifies
this but the Avengers Civil War Infinity
war and Wanda Vision also altered
significant aspects of the MCU with
lasting consequences the introduction of
King the Conqueror into the mix will
affect the MCU in ways that we can't
begin to anticipate likewise secret
Invasion could do the same though the
series Chronicles a shadow war between
Nick Fury's faction and the Scrolls that
doesn't mean that there won't be some
sort of larger Revelation that will
change the MCU more than likely the
knowledge that the Scrolls have been
Among Us will become public and Earth's
citizens likely won't take that very
well beyond that this being Fury's one
last mission also means something while
this won't be the last time we see
Samuel L Jackson in his iconic role how
Fury will make it out alive is still a
question worth asking even if Fury
somehow manages to hide the events of
secret Invasion from the world the
ripples will still be felt throughout
the MCU
thank you